this is one of the funniest clips I
maybe have ever seen on news media
foxnews has really been grasping at
straws over the Trump impeachment
hearings but this is maybe a straw too
far no pun intended because it does
relate to water so George Kent was one
of the first to trump impeachment
hearing witnesses we had last Wednesday
George Kent and William Taylor on Friday
we had Murray Ivanovich George Kent
being a member of Homo sapiens has a
physical body which must consume and
process water throughout the day and the
impeachment hearings were six hours long
and George Kent drank and processed
water during the impeachment hearings
now that's it if you're waiting for some
punch line there is none Fox criticized
Kent for drinking with some clown on the
Laura Ingraham show called this is this
is my favorite new phrase a medical
amount of water which is maybe the
funniest thing I've ever heard as a term
for just drinking water consuming a
medical amount of water take a look at
this he drank a lot of water Lauder
Laura
I mean fish are not this hydrated look
he's always taking [ __ ] look throughout
the hearing took slugs was he on the
treadmill it's amazing it was like a
medical sighs an oxygen chamber water
silo a medical amount of water what does
that mean
he also breathed the medical amount of
air during the hearing he synthesized
vocal cord contractions into speech how
dare he now I have to admit I didn't
notice this and I watched the entire
hearings because I was focused on what
Kent was saying and clearly that was not
an advantageous focus to reinforce the
Fox News narrative so laura ingraham
instead talked about his water drinking
six hours of talking makes sense
you would need water right no he was
taking slugs of medical amounts of water
these people are truly pathetic can you
imagine being so lacking in cognitive
function that you think Fox News counts
as a news channel of some kind the
president is under impeachment inquiry
hearings he's panicking on Twitter
dozens of tweets as these things are
going on attempt to assassinate the
character of the witnesses failing
miserably
and they're talking about a guy being
well hydrated during a six-hour hearing
I was reviewing different commentaries
from the hearings and the Trump
defenders used such terms as
embarrassing theatrics to describe the
hearings somehow I think that
embarrassing theatrics is maybe a phrase
better suited to a segment criticizing a
witness for drinking water this is all
they have now I'm gonna play a clip for
you in a second of Laura Ingraham saying
losers are criticizing this for saying
this if they had more they'd have
focused on it they could the this is a
this is another version of Watergate
right the Laura Ingraham show then
whining about this being discussed
reaction to Raymond Arroyo and myself
joking about State Department official
George Kent's huge water bottle at
yesterday's hearing all right we were
joking about it last night look at these
headlines they devoted headlines to our
joke okay Fox News stunned that
impeachment witness drank water fish are
not this hydrated that was a funny line
well all talk to this on Twitter
including Conway George Conway by the
way he gave a glancing blow to it but we
found it very interesting because not
long ago a lot of these same characters
thought the Republicans Watergate was
actually pretty darn hilarious
hilariously enough the Republican Water
incidents have actually been very
strange
George Kent just drank water that's not
weird Republican Senator Marco Rubio for
example seemingly desperate to quench a
parched throat during a very brief
speech no six-hour marathon like this
was or Donald Trump another example
visibly struggling with his small hands
to drink water having to put both hands
excuse me sorry I punched my Mike both
hands around the glass to hold it
correctly anyway a medical amount of
water this is my new favorite phrase and
clearly very very high level ideas and
indictments of the witnesses happening
over on fox news particularly on the
Laura Ingraham show which you know we've
been wondering what is going to happen
on fox news is there going to be this
split we have seen Judge Andrew
Napolitano continue to make the rounds
Fox & Friends and other shows saying
this doesn't look good for Trump the
facts don't support from snare ative
this is this is potentially criminal so
on and so forth but on the opinion shows
Laura Ingraham Sean Hannity for sure I
have not seen Jeanine Pirro scam in
Terry over the weekend but my guess is
it's probably relatively brown-nosing
they are very clear they're with Trump
they're with Trump for sure the
witnesses aren't credible it's all a
witch hunt it's all terrible and
resorting to phrases like a medical
amount of water to try to ridicule the
witnesses